les enfants jouent tranquillement à la
balançoire on prête à recommencer
voilà à les remparts fallait jumping
jacks
pas question pour les mamans de se
laisser aller
abdou gainage pompe elle se retrouve en
plein air pour une heure de sport
intensif et on va taper à gauche et à
droite
jessica selva jeune maman elle aussi a
concocté un programme infaillible pour
affiner la silhouette qu'elle soit mère
au foyer ou actives elles se retrouvent
pour se motiver et 10 radio au boulot le
sport à la maison c'est un peu plus
compliqué donc là on est toutes ensemble
et on se motive
et puis les papas peuvent surveiller que
en faisant sortir leurs enfants donc
chose qui est super ça va permettre de
de serre et les liens entre les
personnes et les gens sont viennent plus
facilement quand il fait beau que quand
il pleut quoi donc là c'est vraiment
génial
l'occasion de prendre un peu de temps
pour soi un moment entre mamans même si
les enfants ne sont jamais bien loin
comme ysaline huit ans important par 10
par on a tendance à se mettre en dernier
dans la liste des priorités
et là du coup ça nous rappelle qu'on est
une personne à part entière et qu'il
faut prendre soin de soi et ça donne
l'exemple à nos enfants aussi gecip lé
pa professeur de sport mais passionné
par le fitness depuis longtemps les
cours sont totalement gratuit il suffit
de venir anthony et plein de motivation
il ya beaucoup de mamans qui reste
enfermée chez elle est qui et qui dit
qu'on n'en parle pas
qu'ils gardent ça comme un échec au fond
d'elle de pas pouvoir se sentir bien
dans leurs baskets et au final il ya
vraiment une demande et
les gens sont motivés ils en veulent et
c'est bien le rendez vous est fixé une
fois par semaine alors pour celles qui
sont tentés vous n'avez plus d'excusés